hello everybody my name is Martin Warren
welcome to Graydon's attack on titan fan
game if you knew before there was an
attack on titan fan game that was really
fun but this is Ludacris I think whoa
use your speed to turn around the pillar
I know how to do that oh I know I know
how to do that but this one was made to
much more finesse I think oh not quite I
did the weird thing where I just ended
up humping a pillar for a while that was
everything I hope it would be oh my god
well this this is awkward well there we
go off to save the world
ok ok got it ok so this game is real oh
hey oh my god it's just like the show
I'm gonna slice the [ __ ] out of you
press f to charge your attack release
the string
boink oh hey I killed it not quite
perfectly but I did pretty good yeah I'm
an attack on Titan guy I'm the guy
that's gonna get eaten in the first
episode hooray for me all this training
and it paid off for nothing
oh no or they're not actual Titans in
this one yet oh no oh no oh no but at
least I can do some some ability here oh
boy well that's bonus has been lost
already I'm off to a bad start here I'm
not 100% sure on the actual activities
in the game ok here we go here we go
doing some here whoa I look cool at
least not really when I slamming
face-first or grundle first into the
walls nice trajectory I guess finish
Papa Mark oh god I didn't go through the
first dog god I didn't go through the
goddamn giant glowing spheres oh I'm
such an a-hole oh I'm such a horn oh I
did it perfectly
it's all
exactly what I was supposed to do up hit
that wall but that's no biggie okay
we're cool we're cool yeah I got that
one it counted Oh
titties okay bonus has been lost
apparently lost a lot of speed here lost
a lot of speed see somehow even having
to double back all the way to the
beginning I got to see
so obviously this game doesn't have a
lot to show you just yet I mean I can
only do so bad on these things let me
actually try to do this well and I'm
gonna concentrate on this next one but
hopefully in a future edition of the
game they will actually have playable
modes multiplayer games and titans
available to kill so give me two seconds
here and all around it not doing good
man that is tough see I'm not too
terribly good at firing one in one place
and one in the other just yet but that's
kind of like the finesse of it I mean I
only just started the game so I'm not
incredible at it but I still managed to
get a B let me try one of the advanced
ones alright here we go markiplier in
full form here whoosh oh god that's how
its advanced oh Jesus
oh that's not gonna go well for me whoa
hey what are you doing oh hello oh I got
it okay
woo here we go here we go that did a
thing oh that's so cool I can hit it
midair oh I didn't even realize that I
could do that okay huh I got something
it was it was cut that's all it was
that's all though caught it was a cut an
attempt was made it was not good in any
way in fact humanity is now even more
doom than it ah you whiffed on that one
[ __ ] okay hang on you know get this yes
nope yes okay did I do it
bonus lost oh hello that's not what I
had intended was that my oh I see
okay there's more to it oh god damn this
whole time I've been hurt okay so anyway
that's no man I guess I'll try the last
one not that it's gonna go well for me
I'm actually gonna concentrate on this
one really hard this is really hard guys
cuz I mean it's moving very quickly so
it's hard to exactly concentrate on like
the fine things that you're doing ah
goddamn it it's so easy to like
overshoot something and it's easy to
like drop your momentum like obviously
if this is a real thing I would have
fallen and died long before I actually
got a chance to attack a Titan damn it
see it's just like you gotta think like
legitimately on the big balls of your
feet I don't know what that means but
just go with me god damn it it's hard
hardest [ __ ] there we go no why didn't
you go god damn it why didn't you do it
why why did that not do it's really hard
guys you try it you can try the link to
the game is in the description below ah
damn it
ok I give up I am NOT an attack on Titan
master but this one's dead I am a Mikasa
of my own casa
I'm Mikasa of Mikasa so there we go so
that'll be it for now so thank you
everybody so much for watching this is
the attack on Titan fan game made by
gladen
so you can find the link to the game in
the description below you can support
the game because this is awesome there's
a lot of potential here and I bet gamers
that are better than I who are watching
right now can make me look like crap
like you usually do on a daily basis
with how bad I am at games but play this
for yourself see if you can get the high
score on all the time trials and then
hopefully in a later version of game
they'll have an actual battle with
multiplayer and a whole bunch of other
things so
you everybody for watching and as always